hello and welcome back to gain sports
coverage of e3 2015 I'm in man Nathan
fellows here what is going on down in
chris wachowsky pleasure to see you
again sir I know you were coming but why
not it's basically your game he's just
riding on its coattails that's exactly
the summary of gov copy that copy works
yes yes it's your yeah you're just
you're angling up indie developers and
making them work for you no I just we
just get the people who are better than
me and everything and then I take as
much credit as possible you make great
video games and another game people have
been looking forward to it feels like
for feels like a year or two now to you
oh yeah it's been a couple yeah a couple
below and you you're gonna play it right
here yeah yeah chris is gonna Kristin's
gonna guide he's gonna drive and yeah
live demo is our favorite way to show
the game we love kind of just bringing
the game I'm playing it and watching
Chris you know he's really good at the
game because he's the design director of
it but he's probably gonna die anyways
because the game is quite challenging
and brutal but fair but that's the point
right so it is below is the sort of a
wooden exploration roguelike be sort of
yeah it's it's a game about exploration
about survival about discovery it's
inspired by roguelikes it's expired by
adventure games it's it's a game where
you play this tiny wanderer arriving at
this big island walking through a door
and ending up in the depths and we don't
really tell you why you're there or what
you're supposed to do the game really is
about exploring you're exploring the
caves but you're also exploring the
combat the systems the crafting it's a
game that really at every turn the
player is going to be left on their own
to figure out for themselves so I guess
these types of games are often very sort
of their mechanically everything
mechanic is up front like what you see
why you guys need to be doing here is
almost making one of these games that is
just not maybe hiding that but it's
definitely pushing forward a sense of
mood and yes I mean everything that we
make we approach with with the statics
we approach with style that's the thing
that really excites us about
medium is creating stuff that looks a
way that we want something to look and
when we were starting the project Chris
had this idea of doing like 1080p
screens are amazing and they're big and
they have a ton of pixels and most
people use them to get higher res
textures and fidelity and so Chris's
idea was to think about it in terms of
like the screen size as a level and and
what a single screen dungeon game would
be on a 1080p monitor and so we thought
well we'll pull the camera back we'll
use depth of field will really try to
create a game that has a very different
almost like like you're looking into a
little terrarium yeah alive but small
and part of that is because your
character is very weak but it's also
very capable very nimble you have as you
go through the depths you can craft and
crafting is a very important part of
survival Chris just showed some of the
crafting and your crafting to be able to
you know keep yourself alive to give
yourself the tools that you want you
have a sword and shield I you can kind
of duck behind your shield you can poke
around your shield and your that's the
basic combat you can also put one other
weapon there's something yeah let's get
some snacks Nick scarpino just turned up
on the set and game get some shots
thanks Nick yeah you need some food to
survive right exactly yeah he cute it in
you bringing it back around perfect I'm
so explaining sort of the gameplay
what's happening right here what so so
Chris is in one of the one of the levels
of the dungeon this is entirely
procedurally generated every time you
come to the depths the dungeon generates
a new there are landmarks in the dungeon
that don't change but the whole flow all
the levels are procedurally generated
and different every time you arrive I
mean so what Chris is doing is he's
tentatively almost exploring he's making
sure that he's not taking any silly
risks he's got his magical lantern on
which he can you know use or he can pick
up a torch because it also the game is
very dark and light is a very important
piece of it and a line of sight seems to
be very important as well yeah
absolutely it's it's it's really about
not taking any unnecessary risks it's
really about trying to figure out
what the best approach to combat
scenarios are too if you get hit in a
combat scenario you start bleeding and
like in real life if you don't deal with
a wound and we will eventually bleed to
death so in below you are essentially
one hit away from death at every turn
right and that's that's the game the
game will punish you for making
unnecessary mistakes but you don't have
to do that you can figure out for
yourself how to avoid those kind of
nasty situations can we let me look at
some of that you I stuffed a little menu
that's popping well yeah so in there so
you have a couple of different types of
crafting in the game one part of the
crafting is crafting that you do at any
point another part is crafting that you
can only do at fire and that's cooking
that's how you create soups and soups
are kind of like blows potions and by
figuring out the recipes you can kind of
stock yourself up for the long trip down
right you also can pick up different
weapons and very kind of like special
items and you can fill up your Lantern
so that you can reveal parts of the game
like what Chris is revealing right now
and this is you know it's a game that
has a story it's a game that has lore
but we don't have any text or dialogue
in the game we don't have any kind of
like a moments of exposition where we
are forcing you to see the story we just
put hints in put little things for
attentive players to find and even
though we have our own story for the
game we're really hoping that that
players will craft their own narrative
for it we're hoping that we put enough
little breadcrumbs of story that maybe
they'll find what we're looking to tell
them but if they come up with something
different and cooler that's that's
actually kinda ride to excellent open to
interpretation and so as a game where
you can die in one hit and what's it
like resetting are you carrying over
anything are ya so the way that death
works in below is that you're playing a
sequence of lives it's not the same life
over and over again it's not this kind
of like reset the dungeon itself has
things that are that persist through
every life and so any like they major
accomplishments with one life you can
build upon them with your next life then
you show up is a completely different
wonderin dressed differently you might
be female you might be male you might
not really be able to tell but each time
you get to build upon
the success but there are many things in
the game that there are only one of
right which means that let's say you
died with your Lantern there is a
magical lantern in below so if you want
that magic lantern you need to be able
to find your corpse I'll take that
lantern back up and the the game will
give you some hints as to like there is
a mini-map it will show you where the
lantern is but there's very much very
much about you finding your way back to
your body if you want to you don't even
have to I mean again it's a game that
we're trying to create a sense of
delving deeper but also a sense of
control and agency for the player so
what is the end game then is this a game
where you know the end there is a
massive climactic Boston and that's it
and then there's no reason to keep
playing or that I can say very much no
though we really hope that this is a
game that has enough secrets and depth
to it that that there will be multiple
ways for players to find their way to
the end game p um and and even the end
game itself it's part of the exploration
is figuring out why you're even in these
caves what your goal is and why you're
pushing through the depths why you're
trying to go below I mean so even the
endgame is it's something that I'm
really excited to see the first player
get there yeah cuz we're not going to
tell anyone what it is excellent and
it's yeah it's gonna be interesting I
guess seeing the internet unravel the
game and you guys have had that happen
before with super mother's sword and
sorcery and yeah definitely I mean
sorcery we were very explicit about the
story we told that story but there was a
lot in that game for people to find
whether it was through being able to
tweet out lines of dialogue in the game
or whether it was through the mega tome
kind of keeping track of the characters
thoughts in below we're actually hoping
that that goes over to the player that
then that the player will you know take
their own mental notes about landmarks
in the game or story elements that they
notice or things that they might not
want to explore this time but really
want to explore the next step it's that
like we're really we really want to
build a game that has these systems that
interact in an interesting way that
cause the player to want to discover
like in the fuel to feel like they are
the ones that
created that discovery rather than to
feel like we grabbed it by the hand and
dragged them along or what we wanted
them to discover and you're playing on a
PC devkit hear them this come an xbox
one as well yeah it's coming out on pc
and xbox one what it's not part of idea
of xbox it is idea that's that process
been like actually working on Microsoft
I mean it's great we started out the
game started out as a Microsoft Studios
title before idea xbox existed and when
Chris Charla started ID and Xbox we kind
of went to Microsoft and said hey this
is probably a better fit for our game as
an independent developer you know we
were funding them our own title and they
totally agreed they were very supportive
of it and since then I mean it's maybe
they've been supportive of the game from
from day one from the producers all the
way up to Phil Spencer may like they've
been really great about the game they've
been great partners and we're really
excited to be able to bring it to steam
as well that's cool people are excited
to play it as well it's it's one of
those games whenever people see it
they're like oh yeah god I hope that's
coming out soon yeah we definitely have
heard that at e3 that is the common
question and work we're doing our best
to get it out as soon as possible we're
hoping that we can hit later this year
or early next year but really like it's
a it's a very it's a deep game and we
have to kind of we have to excavate the
project while we're actually building
the depths we have to and sometimes you
hit those really challenging layers that
would take a little bit more time to
figure out and as developers giving
ourselves the time yeah to figure out
our game that's the best way that we had
to end up with a project that we can
speak to fans honestly about that we can
when we talk about it they can tell that
we're not full of [ __ ] that we actually
love the thing that we made and we love
this game we really do it's a game like
Chris and I talk about it all the time
it's a game that we made for ourselves I
mean this this thing came from there and
ended up there and that's that's that's
the [ __ ] that we love at copy that's I
was time for us that was taught that was
the sword and sorcery that was clashing
heroes that was critter crunch it like
we've we've really worked hard to get to
that point and the fact that we the fans
have supported us at the fact that we
can have partners and players that are
interested I mean you can't if you look
at it super time force which is coming
to ps4 and Vita very soon
you can play as Shuhei Yoshida I plays
wherever from journey you can play as
Sir Galahad from the order super time
force to below those are some extremely
different games yeah it's okay but
they're at a credit crunch yeah it's
extremely different game and that's what
excites us and we really hope that that
we've seen players that have noticed
that the thread through copy games is it
necessarily a genre but it's like a
style a feel and hopefully a commitment
to making interesting at least I believe
interesting shake that's why people are
excited to play it in that starting why
I'm excited and they think Chris thank
you so much great to see you guys as
ever thanks a lot for having us to any
no worries it's been a long show for you
i'm assuming that we're almost done yep
you got it like slimmer for more of
these but you've been killing it keep it
up man thanks very much do jordan trip
back up north we will enjoy a bit of la
first of all oh yeah cuz i just leavin
chris hanging here i'm sorry buddy he's
over there in your own little world and
i thank you for watching of course on
gamespot com on the YouTube III hub and
of course on hitbox stay tuned we back
with more games and just a minute